[Applaus]
[Musik]
die türkei ist sowas wie paris hilton
oder den staaten dieser welt jedes mal
wenn ihr von den beiden in den
nachrichten hört kann man getrost davon
ausgehen dass jetzt nichts gutes kommt
viele von euch haben uns gefragt wann
wir endlich ein video darüber machen was
in der türkei eigentlich vorgeht und
glaubt mir
die lage ist durchaus gefährlich
[Musik]
erdogan schikaniert europa weil trump in
freie fahrt gewährt hat das spiel das
der türkische präsident recep tayyip
erdogan jetzt mit der migranten krise
treibt ist zu einem großen teil das
ergebnis des freifahrtschein trainer im
vergangenen oktober von trump erhielt
als dieser die us-truppen aus für ihren
abzug nur falls ihr euch fragen solltet
nein dieses mal ist donald trump nicht
an allem schuld tatsächlich ist die
mordrate nur die spitze des eisbergs
eines eisbergs der allerdings das zeug
dazu hat sehr sehr viele schiffe
versenken und ja die schiffe sind in
diesem fall die europäischen banken
schaut einfach mal auf die landkarte die
türkei bildet eine brücke zwischen
europa und asien
wir reden hier über ein land dessen
bevölkerung so groß ist wie deutschland
ein land in das europa seit jahrzehnten
investiert firmen fabriken und natürlich
viele viele kredite
[Musik]
ein beispiel gefällig bitte schön habt
ihr schon mal was von der bbv gehört das
ist spaniens zweitgrößte bank und für
diese bank ist die türkei der
drittgrößte markt oder anders
ausgedrückt wenn die türken mussten
bekommt europa die krippe fürchtet ihr
euch immer noch nicht genug
dann hört jetzt mal gut
[Musik]
die türkei ist eines der wichtigsten
mitglieder der nato verfügt über die
zweitgrößte armee des bündnisses die
größte haben übrigens nur die usa und
sie ist eines der wenigen länder mit
einer muslimischen bevölkerungsmehrheit
und gleichzeitig einer säkularen
verfassung zumindest noch ihr habt euch
nicht erhört da war dieses kleine
wörtchen noch denn die wahrheit ist dass
der türkische präsident
dieser mann er ist nicht gerade der
größte fan eines säkularen staates
wesens also der trennung von religion
und staat sowie der allgemeinen ratlos
bei erdogan ist so was wie der anakin
skywalker der politik genau wie der typ
im film finger an als einen guten aber
wir alle wissen dass er schließlich der
dunklen seite der macht fast in diesem
fall handelt es sich bei der dunklen
seite der macht um eine krude mischung
aus religiösen fanatismus und den guten
alten populismus erdogan stellt sich
gern als den verteidiger des kleinen
mannes da jede türken aus den ländlichen
gebieten wie zum beispiel cholera
vollkommen abseits des bislang bruder
glamours die menschen dort haben keine
atemberaubend und gehälter und sie
pflegen einen eher traditionalistischen
lebensstil und vw müssen sie drinnen
beschützt werden natürlich vor der
verschwörung des bösen bösen westen der
türkei abschaffen will
fakt ist die türkei befindet sich nun
schon seit ganzen drei jahren im
krisenmodus wobei es nicht nur eine
politische krise ist denn das größte
problem ist eigentlich die wirtschaft
wäre hier von einem venezuela im kleinen
aber direkt auf der türschwelle europas
aber was genau ist eigentlich los was
ist dort geschehen dass das ganze land
auf die dunkle seite der wirtschaft
gerät haben mir wirklich gründe und so
große sorgen zu machen heute werden wir
alle diese fragen beantworten aber bevor
wir das
und werfen wir einen blick in die
geschichte
erdogan der erlöse die türkei ist
berühmt für viele dinge die hagia sophia
döner und inflation seit 1970 bis zum
jahr 2000 hatte die türkei immens hohe
inflationsraten in vielen jahren
durchbrachen diese sogar die 100 prozent
marke
das bedeutet dass sich die preise von
jahr zu jahr verdoppelt und was passiert
wenn man so viel inflation hat und sich
in geografischer nähe zu wohlhabenden
europäischen ländern befindet nun man
wird zu einem disneyland für billige
arbeitskräfte
[Musik]
renault und peugeot bauten viele
fabriken der türkei und ich weiß was ihr
jetzt denkt das ist für so ein land doch
eine gute sache nicht wahr
ganz eindeutig ja zum beispiel eröffnete
renault in den 60er jahren eine fabrik
in beuster einer stadt im norden der
türkei die herstellung von autos sind
besser war sehr günstig hören
da die türkische lira jahr für jahr an
wert verlor musste renault umgerechnet
immer niedrigere löhne zahlt und wenn
renault dann das geld aus dem verkauf
dieser autos auf dem konto hatte glaubt
ihr dass sie es nicht sei ließen
natürlich nicht wenn die türkische lira
so schnell an wert verlor war es das
klügste das geld so schnell wie möglich
aus dem land heraus geschaffen aus
diesem grund schien die türkei zur
stagnation verurteilt bis zum jahr 2003
in diesem jahr kam erdogan an die macht
weil hauptziel war es die inflation
unter 10 zu halten so schuf er eine neue
währung die neue türkische lira eine
währung die viel stabiler war als die
vorherige
nachdem die inflation unter kontrolle
gebracht worden war erlebte die
türkische wirtschaft eine wende um 180
grad einmal ganz viele europäische
unternehmen in der türkei zu investieren
darunter viele banken eine von ihnen
die spanische bbva hat in der türkei
über sehr lange zeiträume hinweg
investiert so lange und so intensiv dass
die türkei er drittgrößter markt
geworden ist in den 2000er jahren war
die türkei also total hipp
rechtsstaatlichkeit und
währungsstabilität ermöglichen es
unternehmen ihre kapital im land zu
reinvestieren
in weniger als zehn jahren erhöhte sich
das durchschnittsgehalt eines türkischen
arbeiters von 800 dollar auf mehr als
1200 dollar im monat
aber das war nicht alles in diesen
ersten regierungsjahren erdogans wuchsen
neue industrien heran wie zum beispiel
der tourismus der tourismus in der
türkei fonds von 13 millionen besuchern
auf 39 millionen
und was war mit der türkischen führung
nun habt ihr mal was von turkish
airlines gehört in den 90er jahren war
turkish airlines eine von vielen kleinen
fluggesellschaft aber da sie nun ihre
gewinne die der reinvestierten kunden
wurden sie zu einem giganten der
luftfahrt und glaubt mir
dies ist kein einzelfall
[Musik]
wenn es ein herausragendes beispiel für
das türkische wirtschaftswunder gibt
dann ist es jedes rolex diese firma
begann als eine bäckerei im
familienbesitz und ist mittlerweile
selbst besitzer viele europäischen markt
wo die vocals und united biscuits heute
ist iris holdings das drittgrößte
lebensmittelunternehmen der welt mit
anderen worten die türkische wirtschaft
gehen ab wie nachbars tv und da die
wirtschaft punkte schien es niemanden zu
interessieren dass erdogan mal wegen
seiner mitgliedschaft in einer radikalen
gruppierung im knast gesessen hatte am
ende des tages war das sind immer noch
demokratisch und erdogan war der rock
star des nahen ostens
[Applaus]
[Musik]
man sah in ihm den auserwählten der die
islamische welt auch die helle seite der
macht führen wird
damals wollte die türkei europäisch sein
sie schickte sich an ein mitglied der
europäischen union zu werden
dabei fing alles so schön an als sie
2003 sogar den eurovision song contest
gewann aber wie ihr wisst sind die
verhandlungen zur aufnahme in den club
noch langatmiger als die punktevergabe
beim esc doch dann verlor erdogan die
geduld und er sagte oh ich bin euch wohl
nicht cool genug um in europa
eingelassen zu werden dann ist dir was
ich bin es leid mich so westlich geben
zu müssen mit gewaltenteilung
säkularismus und euren ganzen krimskrams
all das ist jetzt vorbei jetzt kommt die
zeit für in den letzten jahren begannen
die dinge zu erdogan schief zu gehen zum
einen bei persönlich in vielen
korruptionsaffären verwickelt
am schlimmsten aber war nachrichten wie
diese
türkische lira auf dem tiefsten stand
seit 17 monaten aufgrund von sorgen
wegen syrien und corona virus biete
skilehrer fiel auf 1 17 monatige steve
da der konflikt im benachbarten syrien
und die befürchtungen über die
ausbreitung des corona virus bei den
investoren für unruhe sorgten am sonntag
schoss die türkische kampfflugzeuge über
epub und beschoss auch einen weit hinter
das front liegenden luftwaffenstützpunkt
es handelt sich um eine scharfe
eskalation einer militär operation die
auf dem tod dutzender türkischer
soldaten während der letzten woche folgt
die märkte dürften auch die situation an
der griechischen grenze wetter kein auge
behalten wo die griechische polizei
tränengas einsetzen musste um hunderte
von migranten abzuwehren die versuchten
die grenze zu überqueren nachdem ankara
in den grenzübertritt erlaubt hatte
[Musik]
mit seinem militärischen expansionismus
ist syrien möchte sich erdogan seine
popularität bei nationalistischen wlan
sichern und sich als großer feldherr
feiern lassen
dumm nur dass er in militärischen fragen
vollkommen inkompetent ist und nach dem
gescheiterten putsch gegen ihn im jahr
2016 so gut wie alle fäden
militärexperten der türkischen armee
beseitigt hat die sozusagen durch
erdogan enthauptete und nun kopflose
armee hat sich in syrien mittlerweile in
einer nahezu ausweglosen und verdammt
mörderische situation hineinmanövriert
erinnert euch das nicht irgendwie an den
start eines anderen größenwahnsinnigen
politikers mit schnauzbart der sich auch
für den größten armee für aller zeiten
hielt und grandios scheiterte so mies
erdogan aber als militär stratege ist so
geliebt agiert er als aalglatter
politprofi um unseren versagen als
kriegsherr absoluten setzt nun auf eine
gezielt vorsätzliche eskalation der
flüchtlingskrise an der grenze zu
griechenland erdogan kann es sich
nämlich leisten sein perfides erpresser
spielchen mit der eu zu treiben da die
banken sowie die kurzsichtige politik
angela merkels die eu eine gewaltige
abhängigkeit von den launen des
möchtegern sultans gebracht haben jetzt
reizt er seine trümpfe bis zum anschlag
aus und setzt sowohl die türkei als auch
ganz europa dem risiko einer jahrelangen
wirtschaftlichen hängepartie aus
und anstatt die türkei von den unruhen
im nahen osten positiv abzuheben und für
stabilität zu sorgen die ist an allen
fronten auf unberechenbare art öl ins
feuer und verstrickt sein land noch
tiefer in schmutzige geschäft mit dem
terror
denn auch genau diese weise hält er
seine islamische nationalistischen
fanboys dauerhaft bei laune und über
seine milliardenschweren
korruptionsfälle spricht dann auch
keiner mehr dass dies alles gift für die
türkische wirtschaft ist scheint für
erdogan ein vernachlässigbarer preis
dafür zu sein dass er seine eigene macht
im land maximiert die suppe dürfen dann
ohnehin nur unschuldige und wehrlose
auslöffeln
41 tote und 2 130 verletzte bei anschlag
auf den istanbuler flughafen atatürk die
angriffe von 3s brachten den islamischen
terror und die verunsicherung auf die
straßen in der türkei und der schaden
für die tourismusindustrie ließ nicht
auf sich warten in nur zwei jahren
brachen die einnahmen um 25 prozent ein
und dieses besonders schlimm weil der
tourismus für 13 prozent der türkischen
wirtschaft steht aber das ist noch nicht
alles die ausländischen investitionen
sind um die hälfte zurückgegangen und
ihr fragt euch vielleicht warum nun es
gibt zwei gründe dafür
der erste ist die fehlende aussicht dass
die türkei doch noch irgendwann mitglied
der eu werden könnte
der zweite ist erdogan selbst die liebe
zuschauer islamischen radikalismus ist
nicht nur eine gefahr für die politik er
ist auch das schlimmste was der
wirtschaft eines landes passieren können
präsident erdogan zinsen mutter aller
übel türkische lira bricht ein lokal ist
die sogenannte ökonomische orthodoxie
eine westliche erfindung welche die
türkei der stabilisieren wird kredite
und zinsen seien oder islamisch also
zwang er die zentralbank die zinsen zu
senken und geld zu drucken
und was wenn die zinsen banker dagegen
sind das sind transport
die zentralbank an ihre unabhängigkeit
nicht dazu nutzen die signale des
präsidenten zu ignorieren
herr dorn im gespräch mit blume mit
anderen worten nach dem gescheiterten
staatsstreich von 2016 es erdogan
endgültig der dunklen seite der macht
er glaubt dass er die wirtschaft nach
seinem willen gestalten kann und jeden
vernünftigen kritiker gegen seine
wirtschaftspolitik denunziert erdogan
einfach als westlichen verschwörer um
sich nichts mit kritische stimmen herum
plagen zu müssen ernannte er seinen
schwiegersohn in bewährter tradition von
vetternwirtschaft kurzerhand zum
finanzminister bei dieser neuartigen
form von wirtschaftspolitik handelt es
sich weder um freie noch um soziale
marktwirtschaft das ist einfach die neue
erdogan nicht
brauchst du geld um mehrausgaben zu
finanzieren so drucks ist er einfach
klagen sich die türkischen unternehmer
überschwemmen sie einfach mit belegen
krediten in weniger als zwei jahren
haben türkische banken kredite im wert
von mehr als 50 milliarden dollar
vergeben und das alles praktisch zu null
zinsen
das ergebnis die türkische lira wertet
ab wie verrückt im jahr 2014 bekam man
für einen us dollar circa 25 türkische
lehrer als er dieses video drehten
bedruckte wechselkurs bereits mehr als
sechs lehrer pro dollar das heißt dass
die türkische lira auf ein drittel ihres
wertes gesunken ist und das erklärt
warum die inflationsrate 2017 auf 11,9
prozent gestiegen ist
okay okay ich weiß was du denkst 11,9
prozent das hört sich noch nicht so
schlimm an oder energie zum beispiel
haben sie drei mal so viel inflation die
wahrheit ist dass es zwischen der
abwertung einer währung und dem anstieg
der verbraucherpreise immer eine gewisse
zeitliche verzögerung gibt wer leidet
als erster an den folgen dieser
abwertung nun das wären vor allem
diejenigen unternehmen die kredite bei
ausländischen banken aufgenommen haben
und es gibt mehr als nur ein paar davon
erinnerst du dich an den
lebensmittelkonzern jedes ho links jetzt
geht's los
[Musik]
türkischer besitzer von codia chocolate
muss 6,5 milliarden dollar schulden
restrukturieren
schätzungen gehen davon aus dass die
auslandsschulden türkischer unternehmen
300 milliarden dollar übersteigen zum
besseren verständnis dieses der gleiche
betrag der für alle rettungsaktionen in
griechenland ausgegeben wurde und
inzwischen beginnt die inflationsrate
allmählich zu steigen
[Musik]
die türkei fällt auf schrott niveau
standard and poor's sieht für nächstes
jahr rezession voraus inmitten dieses
ganzen schlamassels gibt es einen
anderen spieler der sehr viel zu
verlieren hat und das ist die
europäische union
[Musik]
banken wie die spanische bbva die
französische bnp paribas oder die
italienische unicredit haben türkischen
unternehmen mehr als 190 milliarden
dollar geliehen bisher hat bbva bereits
die hälfte des wertes dieser
investitionen verloren man kann sich
also schon die gewaltige lücke
vorstellen die einen zusammenbruch des
türkischen kreditmarkt zu hinterlassen
würden
bislang hat erdogan behauptet beim
internationalen währungsfond nicht um
rettung betteln so wollte und auch keine
kapitalkontrollen einzuleiten dh die
ausführungen von kapital aus der türkei
nicht zu verbieten aber weiß ob er
überhaupt die wahl haben wird sein wort
zu halten wir wissen es nicht wir wissen
nur dass sowohl katar als auch china
versprochen haben der türkischen
wirtschaft oder die arme zu greifen aber
noch ist es zu früh abzusehen wie das
alles enden wird
[Musik]
und jetzt fragen wir euch wirke türkei
zu einem eigenen venezuela europas kann
diese krise eine größere krise in ganz
europa auslösen wird erdogan alle auf
die dunkle seite ziehen
bitte schreibt eure meinungen und
einschätzungen dazu in den
kommentarbereich unter dieses video und
denkt daran dass wir jede woche
brandneue videos veröffentlichen also
clicker fabulieren um ja keinen beitrag
zu verpassen wenn dir dieses video
gefallen hat betont sein like und wie
immer bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]